deutschland trauert um zwei junge
polizisten
polizeianwärterin jasmin b und
oberkommissar alexander k standen noch
in der blüte ihres lebens als dieses
ihnen genommen wurde jasmin b war gerade
mal 24 jahre alt und stand kurz vor
ihrem abschluss bei der polizei es war
ihr zweiter einsatz auf streife ihr
junger kollege alexander k war 29 jahre
alt und arbeitete bei der polizei als
oberkommissar aber leidenschaftlicher
fußballspieler im fußballclub fc freisen
19 20 der verein steht unter schock und
trauert um den freund spieler und
geliebten kameraden zwei junge menschen
die eine lücke hinterlassen bei familie
freunden und auch in ganz deutschland
nur natürlich versinkt kusel dieser
kleine ort in trauer aber auch ganz
deutschland schaut auf dieses örtchen in
rheinland pfalz wo heute abschied von
jasmin und alexa alexander genommen wird
unsere reporterin da jeder fahrt die ist
genau dort wo in wenigen minuten die
trauerfeier mit familie freunden und
geladenen gästen aus der politik beginnt
und es wird auch eine schweigeminute
geben daniela ich bin sicher die
stimmung in kusel ist gedrückt heute
ja das stimmt diese trauerfeier hier
heute in kusel findet unter ausschluss
der öffentlichkeit statt das bedeutet
dass auch wir journalisten
beispielsweise gar nicht die möglichkeit
haben an dieser veranstaltung
teilzunehmen
geladen sind rund 200 gäste darunter
sind auch die familien der beiden
getöteten polizisten aber auch direkte
kollegen sowie die ministerpräsidentin
von rheinland pfalz malu dreyer und der
innenminister
lewentz die stimmung ist gedrückt der
polizeipräsident sagte vor hin dass es
wohl der schwerste tag für die kollegen
hier heute ist denn es ist eine art
abschied nehmen
die trauerfeier unter ausschluss der
öffentlichkeit also ist natürlich auch
verständlich aber was kannst du uns
berichten vielleicht von den erwarteten
gästen die da sind von von der lage vor
ort
ich konnte vorhinein mal kurz in dieser
halle hinein schauen das ist ein
abgedunkelter raum die halle befindet
sich hier im hintergrund in der mitte
dieses raumes stehen zwei große fotos
von addex und jasmin den beiden
getöteten polizisten
später sollen dann auch noch zwei kerzen
entzündet werden ein musikkorps wird
spielen und alles in allem soll es ein
stilles gedenken sein es wird zwar
ansprachen geben auch von der
ministerpräsidentin aber alles ganz im
zeichen des stillen gedenkens und das
abschied nehmen
daniela dankeschön für den moment wir
werden natürlich dann gleich noch einmal
jetzt wo dir schauen wenn es dann los
geht's
da diese tat und auch das motiv lassen
ein ja wirklich fassungslos zurück muss
man sagen die mutmaßlichen polizisten
mörder waren ja wilderer die
offensichtlich ihre beute schützen
wollten um 10 uhr wird es dann
bundesweit eine schweigeminute geben und
bereits gestern gab es einen bewegenden
trauergottesdienst
deutschland mit abschied von zwei helden
polizeianwärterin jasmin b und
oberkommissar alexander kahr wurden am
ersten februar brutal hingerichtet
dieser doppelmord schock ganz
deutschland die bluttat von kusel wird
noch lange in erinnerung bleiben
am abend um 19 uhr 30 evangelische
kirche in kusel
[Musik]
die gemeinde und kollegen der
verstorbenen gedenken der opfer die
stimmung ist gedrückt die trauer ist
groß in diesen stunden
für mich sind das niedrige
die mich erschüttern tief zutiefst
erschüttern der mich den glauben an die
menschheit
zweifeln lässt dass so etwas passieren
kann wir leben hier im landkreis zurzeit
eine unheimliche betroffenheit
zutiefst schockiert und sprach
einfach nur fassungslos diese brutale
tat ist so unvorstellbar dass wir alle
zusammenhalten müssen ganz klar uns auch
bekennen müssen zur polizei zu unseren
ordnungskräften wacht meisterinnen
wachtmeister sind schutzleute die daraus
auf der straße unterwegs sind und für
unser aller sicherheit sorgen und wenn
dann jemand auf so tragische weise das
leben genommen kriegt und dann zerreißt
es einem das herz ich habe am montag die
nachrichten gelesen war wirklich
erschüttert so etwas grausames kommt ich
mir nie vorstellen aber passiert ich bin
der meinung polizeigewalt in deutschland
hat so zugenommen ganz schlimm
deutschland hat meiner meinung kein
problem mit polizei gewalt sondern mit
gewalt gegen die polizei das sollte man
dringend etwas unternehmen ich bin
erschüttert man kennt die kollegen die
hier bei der polizei sind die menschen
in kusel sind bis ins mark erschüttert
es ist ein abschied für immer von diesen
beiden jungen menschen die jetzt nicht
mehr unter uns sind
o
[Musik]
ja und gleich um punkt 10 uhr fällt ganz
deutschland für eine minute den atem an
also in drei bis vier minuten es wird
der beiden getöteten kollegen gedacht
alle polizeipräsidien sind aufgerufen
sich an dieser schweigeminute zu
beteiligen
und wir schauen jetzt auf die
polizeistationen in dresden münchen in
berlin und auch in essen und wir sehen
das natürlich wahnsinnig viel los ist
auch auf bei diesen polizeistationen die
ganzen kolleginnen und kollegen sind da
haben sich eben vor ihre stationen vor
ihre wagen gestellt um eben dann gleich
alle gemeinsam bei dieser trauerfeier
bei dieser schweigeminute teilzunehmen
um punkt 10 uhr geht es dann eben los
bis es soweit ist können wir natürlich
auch noch mal schauen auf das was wir
inzwischen wissen auch über die beiden
täter da gibt es ja inzwischen auch
wieder ein paar neue informationen beide
waren ja offensichtlich wilderer die
ihre beute schützen wollten und das
lässt einen natürlich wirklich
fassungslos zurück jetzt sehen wir hier
gerade dresden dort haben sich auch die
polizisten und polizistinnen schon
positioniert und warten eben jetzt schon
gebannt darauf dass es diese
schweigeminute geben wird ein wirklich
sehr sehr große anteilnahme selten haben
wir sowas hier in deutschland gesehen
dass tatsächlich ja so bewegt diese
toten polizisten gedacht wird hier jetzt
die bilder aus münchen
auf der theresienwiese haben sich die
kolleginnen und kollegen der polizei
versammelt und gedenken den beiden
getöteten die 24 jährige jasmin k und
ihr 29 jähriger kollege alexander und
hier sehen wir die bilder aus berlin wie
die kollegen hier gedenken die
schweigeminute einleiten
und schauen gleich auch noch mal weiter
hier sehen wir jetzt alle vier
polizeistationen noch einmal gemeinsam
wir haben es jetzt 9 uhr 59 also in
genau einer minute wird dann eben diese
schweigeminute staaten hier sehen wir
jetzt nochmal das polizeipräsidium essen
auch die fahnen sind natürlich auf
halbmast geflaggt an diesem jahr
wirklich auch sehr traurigen tag muss
man sagen was wir wissen man könnte
natürlich sagen andreas s der
mutmaßliche haupttäter er war ein
wilderer er hatte wohl auch großhandel
mit gebildeten fleisch betrieben und das
scheint ja nun auch offensichtlich das
grausige motiv gewesen zu sein weswegen
er und der mittäter diese beiden jungen
polizisten direkt erschossen hat und wir
wollen jetzt alle gemeinsam auch einmal
kurz innehalten und eben bei dieser
schweigeminute mitmachen und den beiden
polizisten gedenken
[Musik]
ein sehr bewegender moment den wir jetzt
hier gerade erlebt haben in ganz
deutschland bundesweit halten die
polizistinnen und polizisten innen nicht
nur sie auch viele menschen in der
bevölkerung viele zivilisten haben sich
dieser schweigeminute angeschlossen um
eben diesen beiden jungen getöteten
polizisten zu gedenken ein wirklich sehr
bewegender moment hier sehen wir jetzt
die bilder aus dresden münchen aus
berlin und auch außen
immer noch einmal zu daniel abfahrt
schauen daniela hat diese schweigeminute
natürlich auch mitgemacht daniela du
bist in kusel das ist natürlich noch mal
ein ganz besonderer ort um diese
schweigeminute mitzunehmen wie hast du
das ganze wahrgenommen
ja genau ich stehe vor der halle
praktisch in kusel in der diese
gedenkfeier jetzt in diesen minuten
stattfindet und auch hier haben die
beamten die polizisten die vor der halle
stehen diese schweigeminute eingehalten
und es ist ein bedrückendes gefühl ich
sehe es hier so aus dem augenwinkel ein
polizeiauto das blaulicht blinkt ist es
bedrückend
daniela diese trauerfeier wird dir du
hast schon gesagt unter ausschluss der
öffentlichkeit stattfinden was kannst du
uns trotzdem über den ablauf des ganzen
sagen
genau ich konnte voll mal kurz in die
halle schauen das ist ein abgedunkelter
raum zwei große fotos von alex und von
jasmin den beiden getöteten polizisten
stehen dort in der mitte des raumes es
wird dann ein musikkorps spielen es
sollen zwei kerzen angezündet werden es
wird auch einige kleine ansprachen geben
unter anderem von der
ministerpräsidentin von malu dreyer von
rheinland pfalz aber ansonsten ist das
ganze ein stilles gedenken
vielen dank für diesen moment aus
rheinland pfalz aus kusel wo die
trauerfeier aktuell stattfindet daniela
barth